foreign
bobert
what
here you go is congresswoman Lauren
bobert says she was removed from a show
at the Denver Center for Performing Arts
over the weekend this is new video from
the city of Denver showing the incident
she could get it though
yo yo yo hey girl what's up I don't even
care that she came from a talent agency
we get to look at her yeah an Israeli
pornographers talent agency
I don't even care that she's [__]
[__] well she's a woman first if you
care that they're [__] okay yeah
I really hope she wasn't escorted out
during the Deo scene she looks like an
escort actually we're talking yeah
smash though right like smash yeah
Hearts oh yeah she looks like a Vegas
hooker yeah it really does probably
problems like one
congresswoman Lauren bobert says she was
removed from a show at the Denver Center
for Performing Arts over the weekend
this is new video from the city of
Denver showing the incident here showing
bobert and a man being escorted out they
are accused of vaping singing loudly and
causing a disturbance vapings
honestly that makes me like her more she
is such a trash bag I love her that
makes me like her even more broken I'm
still amazed that she's a [__]
Colorado politician she just screams
Florida right smash though right like
hard smack she should be one of our
[__] congresswomen she just fits in
Florida vaping singing loudly like just
did you see the Virginia one the one
that was the the Democrat one that was
also on only fans with her husband like
doing you know yeah
yeah yeah I've seen one of my sitting
Congress people suck a dick
I saw all the videos wait I did I didn't
I you don't live in South Carolina
foreign
here showing bobert and a man being
escorted out they are accused and a man
it's not even her husband and a man I
thought she just got divorced oh she did
they did they find okay yeah yeah she
got there just just got divorced like oh
she's fresh on the market dog yo she is
[__] fine she's so hot and by the way
Mercer if you want the link to the
Virginia uh one I can give you those too
she's also really hot freshly divorced
and Mommy's already hunting oh yeah
Mommy's already out there looking
they are accused of vaping singing
loudly and causing a disturbance bober
tweeted after the answer enjoying
themselves [__] them
quote it's true I did thoroughly enjoy
the amazing Beetlejuice at the Buell
Theater and I plead guilty to laughing
too loud everyone should go see it if
you get the chance this week and please
let me know and everybody sneaks of Vape
when they're out and out inside shut up
yeah honestly I I hate Lauren bobert
she's a [__] [__] and she's a
cringe Factory but let's be honest you
were you just wanted to catch Lauren
bobert you're gonna get a story yeah
they're complaining about people hitting
[__] weed Vapes in Colorado in a
theater like come on now it wasn't even
it wasn't a weed Vape it was uh so that
that [__] is smoking a weed Vape
[Laughter]
she wasn't hitting a jewel yeah I love
how [__] matter of fact and
confidence
shut up from the city
decent ass for a white chick I would
[__] the dog [__] out of Lauren bober
come on like a [__] screen door in a
hurricane
[Music]
would [__] you and then kick you out too
like you wouldn't even have to deal with
any awkwardness
like you know you ever hook up with a
chick and you're like how am I gonna get
out of here afterwards and then they're
cool and they're like look I got a lot
of work in the morning so bye you know
you should probably get going and you're
like oh oh yeah so cool uh you got my
number uh you know keep on trucking
and then and then the entire time Mercer
in this car I go did I say keep on
trucking
and I never have to ask myself that I
got you goddamn right I did
it out they are accused of vaping
singing loudly and ghosts are fake
titties right
so absolutely they're accused of having
fun at a concert yeah who cares those
are fake those are definitely fake
titties yeah but they're not like the
old bolt-ons those are hermetically
sealed yeah vaping singing loudly and
all right guys come on listen that's a
sitting congresswoman we're being very
good
I wish you're sitting on my face
look guys enough
look I want to apologize you know to the
people that Rumble you know that that uh
they know we're a eyebrow show okay and
I want to apologize for these guys and
uh uh to congresswoman Lauren bobert um
I want to eat your [__]
they want to impeach
Ed nice Face-Off reference that was
really good that was really good when I
put my face on her [__] hurts dude
she's smoking hot
on the right night you have a chance
you think
anybody does not on any night but on the
right night yeah you run into Lauren
bobert on the right night you got a shot
like Lauren bobert's one of those like
if you get her like in Vegas on a night
when she just followed her boyfriend oh
you know you're in yeah
there we go you know you meet her at the
MGM she's crying in front of a slot
machine smoking a cigarette you're like
I'm in